so let's talk about me leaving corridor
[Music]
I'm see Mike
Carmichael David Carmichael surprised
Carmichael is not my first name I have
been the showrunner one of the two video
shooters editors of this channel it's
kind of nervous talking to you I printed
out the things I want to say I am
leaving corridor I'm leaving on my terms
I'm not leaving tomorrow I'm not leaving
next week my last day will be at the end
of May 2019 that will be about five
years there'll be five years of working
at corridor digital about four years
working on the vlog I really don't know
what to say some of you might be like no
you're the best you're the nicest dude
whatever Thanks but Nick's staying
Nico's still here Sam still here Jake
still here Wren Clint they're all still
here
Christian Gabe occasionally the Sun so
interesting we started the vlog at every
other day and those were two and a half
minute long videos it is the year 2016
it's a new year and the new year new
things I'll put the playlist down below
watch it from the beginning in two years
we were still doing every other day but
they got up to ten minutes and longer so
exhausting this was not an easy decision
to come to I pretty much spent most of
this year thinking about it it started
with some realizations about myself some
deep dives of who I am and what I am
it's time for me up here to experiment
and grow somewhere else as well this is
the first time in my life that I've
worked with a team I've learned
something kind of unique from everyone
Nico taught me a lot about being an
artist taught me how to use the red and
Nico's even gone to the lengths of
showing me how to set up a retirement
plan not many bosses peers and
co-workers would do that for you we've
been working with someone for a long
time you evolve with them one of the big
things I learned from Carmichael was how
to be an artist that has his own Drive
and passion in other artists their
driving passion how do you work together
to create a fostering environment for
that these days it's easier for me to
collaborate with other artists
other people who are passionate because
of working with Carmichael good old Sam
Sam's like Picasso he puts everything he
knows everything he feels in every
creative idea he has he brings this
level of extreme extreme passion to the
projects he works on these does not
backed down from his idea and tell
there's a better idea in the room well
one thing that left an impression on me
from Carmichael's that he's got this
post-it note on his desk that says kill
babies
that's a post-it note that I need on my
desk - with the amount footage let's go
through the amount of edits you have to
be ready to let go you know not
everything's precious and especially
when you're in filmmaking an art form
you have to be ready to I guess let go
of ideas whether you wanted them to work
out and they didn't in any aspect of
your life kill babies I try and channel
that Jake working with him
is taught me a lot about how to balance
art and commerce so that way you can
deliver something but your artistic
vision isn't sacrificed oftentimes when
he first started here we would argue a
lot more than we do now and the reason
is because I I wasn't listening you know
they say God gave you two ears and one
mouth because you should listen twice as
much as you speak
that's actually really true because of
the process that I went through with him
I had learned I relearned that a lot of
footage for a simple thing Nick I'm
sorry Ren Ren it show himself every
single day it's amazing he's smart he's
logical but he trusts his heart and it
makes him honest after filming around
for five years I've learned how
important it is to be the person who
naturally are did you know that
Carmichael when he first started working
here this isn't like what 2014 he was a
janitor mopping the floors cleaning the
bathrooms and look at look at where
we're at over four years later
Carmichael has a way of distilling
information down into something that
everyone will understand and he'll just
straight up stop maybe like no Joe from
the gas station down the street is not
going to understand what you're saying
we have to figure out a way to simplify
it without it being wrong and so that
has helped me learn to better explain
science in ways that I think most people
will understand rather than just the few
who will get the scientific
and all that stuff Nick next a
hard-working dude he's also really good
at keeping his cool yeah I'm I'm all in
kind of a person sitting next to Nick
for the last few years working with him
I've learned how to chill the out so
thank you Nick Carmichael has taught me
how to be a bit more emotional in the
sense of if there's something that I
feel passionate about I can express that
more and like he serves as a good
example of that I mean we still have
like three or four months to work
together it's that like it's leaving
tomorrow
the reason we're making this video now
is because well you'll find out tomorrow
we're going with Christian Christian's
crazy example on how to handle such
massive workloads and to still be chill
under pressure
I see Christian doing three four things
at a time and it's insane to watch him
enjoy it but something I hope I can do
someday but I didn't mean Carmichael
till my first day working here at
quarter whole time you know about two
years ago he really took the time to you
get to know me right away you know over
these next two years we from not only as
friends but you know colleagues and we
work all together so Carmichael truly is
one of the nicest dudes Clanton dude I
think the name I'm doing a video that's
very personal
yeah the oat milk that's in the jar
right there yeah that's all for you son
really that half yeah sweet pulsar thing
sounds awesome
yeah I'm gonna use it for a protein
shake yeah this is the divine video dang
Clint C's learning something new is a
good thing as a positive thing he's
passionate about learning more such as
like how to zero waste and whatnot you
know
he has a passion for learning that
Carmichael has grown very much as a
person in the last the last year and a
half that I've known him and that makes
me very very happy
and I just wish comment goes best in his
future endeavors and I know that he's in
be all right Gabe Gabe works a lot he's
here after he works here for a full day
he goes to his wife's clothing store he
works there
after that he gets ready to go teach so
he has three jobs every week he still
has a smile
he's kind it's also got cool beard I
have a cool beard but his beard cycle
like a badass beard I won that first
since he did just shoot me with the nerf
gun that's like I don't even know this
guy you just like [ __ ] oh shoot me
slowly the long arrows here the congos
the funniest guy nicest guy and he works
really hard that's one thing I
appreciate the works is that song
Jarrett
I've known Jarrett for a year but he's
also become one of my closest friends
Jarrett is a really smart funny guy and
now that he's working on the podcast I
hope you enjoy that podcast and he's
putting a lot of effort and time into
because all that time that he's putting
into that podcast is taking away from us
playing D&D every Sunday enjoy it
Carmichael has an incredible attention
to detail how did you come to the
conclusion you came to you notices this
detail and extrapolates forward and I
try to apply that to my own thinking
with okay what do I want and where does
it start and kind of have what
Carmichael approached this and that's a
very different way of thinking really
pretty cool at a certain point all these
guys have taught me how to work as a
team how to be humble around everyone
how to respect another person better how
to communicate better I don't think I'd
be the person I am right now if I did
work at corridor digital it's the last
five years basically starting next year
I'll be here training and walking in the
next person to work on this channel I
hope you have enjoyed the work that I am
NIC have put on this channel the videos
aren't changing the guy behind the cam
changing oh you know what you're missing
is hello darkness all right I know that
that's a lot of information and it might
come off as jarring or shocking you
might be thinking the channel was
changing everything's changing the world
is going to [ __ ] but guess what
the coridor crew Channel and the show
that exists on it will continue we're
gonna continue to make videos our
Michael's gonna be here to work
alongside an editor more on that
tomorrow if you think that person is you
the point is don't panic guys the show
must go on and it will okay I mean I was
gonna panic for a second well the
channel might be changing but I found
out it's not one more really important
thing to say for those of you who missed
out on the Black Friday merch cut to
this here's a here's a word from our
sponsor I know some of you missed out on
some of the Black Friday items because
we sold out so fast but my popular
demand we brought back the black floral
long sleeve and the knitted logo beanie
so these are available now and if you
order them in the next couple of days
they will arrive before Christmas in
addition as a thank you to you guys who
wanted to get an item but couldn't
because it was out we're doing 15% off
on all items in the store from now until
Christmas that's all items corridor
digital dot store 15% off this is back
this is back whatever else is in the
store it's 15% off thank you
[Music]